identify all acute obtuse and right
angles in the image below so let's just
remind ourselves what an what an acute
uptooth or right angle is an acute angle
is an angle that is less than 90 degrees
and i'll write it right over right under
the word acute a right angle
a right angle is an angle that is equal
to 90 degrees or whose measure is equal
to 90 degrees and an obtuse angle
obtuse angle is an angle that is greater
than 90 degrees
greater than 90 degrees and it is less
than 180 degrees or you could view it
this way it is greater than 90 degrees
or 90 degrees is less than an obtuse
angle and an obtuse angle is less than
180 degrees and they don't ask us about
this but if you have an angle that is
180 degrees it forms a straight line and
that really is called a straight angle
so let's look at this diagram and let's
start with the acute angles and i'll do
i'll do the acute angles in purple ones
ones that we know are less than 90
degrees
well you look over here the only real
information they've given is they've
marked this box right over here that
this angle right over here is a right
angle so actually let's start with the
right angle because that actually might
be a little bit more interesting so they
tell us that this right over here is a
right angle so we already know one of
the right angles is angle q
a r where a would be the vertex you
could also call it angle raq
so angle
qar
q a r they actually tell us the measure
of that is actually 90 degrees
now there is another 90 degree angle
here and that is qat
this angle right over here
angle q
a t and the reason why i know that angle
q a t is also right is that if you take
qar
if you take qar which was this one over
here and combine it with qat you
actually form a straight angle you go
all the way around like this and so
their sum needs to be 180 degrees so if
qar is 90 degrees then qat also has to
be 90 degrees another way to think about
it is so is because
they're next to each other they actually
have an array in common they are
adjacent angles and if you were to put
them and when you look at if you look at
their outer edges that you actually form
a straight angle you would call these
two angles supplementary or that they
add up to 180 degrees that's another
definition of supplementary they add up
to 180 degrees therefore if one is 90
the other one has to be 90 degrees
so with that out of the way now let's
look at the now let's look at the acute
angles because that actually gives us a
lot of information because of this
entire angle if qat
if qat is 90 degrees then any of the
angles that that make up qat have to be
less than 90 degrees so for example qap
that angle right over there q a p the
measure of that angle has to be less
than 90 degrees because it's part of
this larger 90 degree angle you'd have
to add that to this angle right over
here to actually get to 90 degrees so
both of them actually have to be less
than 90 degrees so one acute angle is
angle qap
q
a p and then another acute angle is
angle p a t
angle p a t and once again we know that
because if we add these two angles
together you get 90 degrees so each of
them have to be less than 90 and we're
assuming that neither of these angles
are 0 degrees now are there any other
acute angles over here well another
angle that looks acute is angle ras
angle r
a s and the reason that we can feel
pretty good that it is less than 90
degrees is because if you were to keep
this line if you if
aq is just a ray right now but if you
were extended all the way let's say you
had some mythological point over there
called x
called x angle r a x would be 90 degrees
and so r a s is less than that so ras
has to be less than 90 degrees and i
think we got all of the acute all of the
acute angles here we got the two right
angles here now let's think about the
obtuse angles the ones that are more
than 90 degrees and less than 180
degrees so one of the obtuse angles
one of the obtuse angles is if you went
from q
q a
s
or s a q let's call it saq saq is
definitely an obtuse angle because it
contains a 90 degree angle in it and
it's even wider than that so saq
angle
s a q
is definitely obtuse i'd be tempted to
say s a p but sap is a straight angle if
we went all the way around like this 180
degrees that would actually be a
straight angle and that's not officially
an obtuse angle notice it's called a
straight angle because it forms a
straight line the two rays the two edges
of the angle form a straight line so
we're not going to include we're not
going to include sap there
now another obtuse angle another obtuse
angle i'll do this in a different color
looks like r
a p
angle
r
a p once again it contains r a q in it
which is 90 degrees then it opens up
even wider it opens up even wider than
that and let's see an r a t is a
straight angle so for our purposes we
will not consider that obtuse and have i
found everything have i found everything
am i not missing something so i did that
one i did that one and those would be
straight angles
oh wait i just saw one more of course
you also have this angle right over here
it's a big blank spot and i wasn't
paying attention to it you also have
this angle right over here angle tas
angle t
a s and the reason why we know it's more
than 90 degrees is once again if you had
this mythological point x over here that
was just if you were continue if you
were to continue q a in this direction
we would know that this is a 90 degree
angle and tas is opening up more than
that 90 degree angle so tas is also
is also obtuse and i think i got all of
them now so let me see i think that is
all of them yep we're done